[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 el congreso
española aprobó reformas de ley
históricas para los derechos de las
mujeres y de la comunidad diversa las
mujeres desde los 16 años ahora podrán
en ese país interrumpir sus embarazos
libremente hasta las 14 semanas habrá
una baja por menstruación dolorosa y el
cambio de género será libre y sin
exámenes también a partir de los 16 años
Este es el reporte de Valentina Sánchez
gracias gracias por la antiguas deudas
con las mujeres y personas trans en
España así han sido calificadas las
nuevas leyes aprobadas por el congreso
la ley sobre el aborto elimina el
requisito de autorización de los padres
para jóvenes de 16 y 17 años yo creo que
aquí hay una cuestión muy importante en
primer lugar en relación al aborto está
claro que si yo con 16 años Soy lo
suficientemente madura y adulta como
para traer al mundo a una criatura y
sacarla adelante con todo lo que implica
al menos las personas que hemos sido
madres o padres Yo creo que por lo tanto
también tengo la capacidad de tomar una
decisión tan importante como de no tener
esa criatura las mujeres y personas con
capacidad para gestar mayores de 16 años
podrán abortar libremente hasta las 14
semanas de gestación hasta las 22 por
riesgo para la vida o la salud de la
madre o anomalías graves del feto y en
Casos excepcionales después de esa fecha
la norma además elimina la obligación de
informar a los gestantes sobre opciones
alternas al aborto y sobre el plazo de
reflexión de tres días sobre la
interrupción del embarazo la ley para la
igualdad real y efectiva de las personas
trans y para la garantía de los derechos
de las personas lgtbi también conocida
como ley trans garantiza la
autodeterminación de género y establece
los 16 años como único requisito para el
cambio legal de sexo elimina la
hormonación hasta ahora obligatoria y
Las evaluaciones psicológicas y médicas
los menores de entre 14 y 16 años
tendrán que realizar el trámite con sus
padres o tutores al tiempo que los
menores entre 12 y 14 requieren
autorización judicial
hoy la libertad hoy la diversidad hoy el
respeto gana a la intolerancia gana al
odio y gana los culos hoy España es
mejor país para todas no solamente para
las personas trans además se adoptó una
medida pionera en Europa y es la baja
por menstruación incapacitante asociada
a patologías como la endometriosis y
vamos a conversar sobre esta noticia y
para eso está en ellas hoy nuestra
invitada Ana requena Aguilar ella es
redactora jefa y experta en género del
diario punto es Ana bienvenida Gracias
por estar con nosotros
Hola qué tal pues mire Ana vamos a
empezar hablando un poco de lo que se
contaba en el reportaje y es el Por qué
se han fijado los 16 años como una edad
que es clave para el derecho a decidir
Comencemos por el derecho a la
interrupción del embarazo y después
hablamos y le parece de la definición
del género y de la sexualidad de una
persona
Pues a ver que en España la ley de
plazos que aprobó el gobierno de
zapatero en 2010 ya contemplaba el
derecho de las mujeres menores de 16 y
de 17 años a interrumpir voluntariamente
su embarazo sin necesidad de
autorización paterna Qué sucedió que
unos años después el gobierno del
partido popular quiso llevar a cabo una
reforma de la ley del aborto que
finalmente se quedó en eliminar otra vez
ese derecho para las mujeres de 16 y 17
años en autorización paterna lo que hace
esta Norma que aprobó este jueves el
congreso de los diputados es recuperar
el derecho No es decir que España ya
había tenido este debate en 2010 sobre A
qué edad Desde qué edad poder abortar
libremente se resolvió de una manera
hemos pasado unos años en los que bueno
las menores necesitaban esa autorización
paterna pero digamos que ahora lo
recuperan tal y como se contemplaba en
la Norma que se aprobó en Hace 13 años
bien eso es por un lado con el tema de
la interrupción del embarazo ahora está
el tema de la llamada ley trans y que a
partir de los 16 años tampoco tendrán
trabas de ningún tipo para hacer un
cambio de género eventual eso es ahí la
edad también clave son los 16 porque
Bueno pues en ambos casos se entiende
que hay madurez suficiente para tomar la
decisión y además en el caso del cambio
de sexo registral también se permite en
el caso de los menores de 16 años solo
que con autorización judicial en el caso
de los menores entre 12 y 14 años
necesitan áreas necesitarán el aval de
un juez o de una jueza y entre los 14 y
los 16 necesitan el consentimiento
paterno Y a partir de esa edad en la que
se considera que hay madura es
suficiente Bueno pues ya Sin condiciones
simplemente por la por la propia
voluntad ahora uno de los requisitos que
se van con esta reforma en la ley trance
es por ejemplo la hormonación que antes
era obligatoria por dos años y además
Las evaluaciones psicológicas y otro
tipo de exámenes aquí yo voy a hacer una
interpretación y usted nos va a explicar
Si eso no correcta Y es que había cierto
paternalismo no en esta decisión y es
Piénsalo bien Está seguro vamos a hacer
unas evaluaciones para saber si
efectivamente eres una persona elegible
para hacer este cambio y esto podría ser
visto eventualmente como una forma de
discriminación o o la incapacidad de la
persona para tomar la decisión sobre
cómo quiere expresarse Y cómo quiere
autopercibirse
claro era sobre todo una
patologíalización porque al final el
hecho de que una persona necesitara dos
años de hormonación y también un informe
médico que le diagnosticara disforia de
género hacía pasar a esa persona por
todo un proceso médico en el que bueno
su voluntad no bastaba no era sometida a
una serie de criterios externos
para poder después cambiar no esa
mención registral de su sexo con lo cual
España tenía una ley de identidad de
género que permitía todo esto y que
bueno sí que ponía a disposición no de
las personas pues este tipo de
tratamientos las unidades de de género
en los hospitales pero no estaba
cumpliendo con Los estándares
Internacionales ahora mismo que ya van
No desde hace unos años por esa
despatologización es lo que está
diciendo la Organización Mundial de la
Salud es lo que está diciendo diversos
organismos internacionales y en general
la jurisprudencia sobre sobre Derechos
Humanos está señalando a los estados que
debe despatologizarse ese proceso de
cambio de sexo y es lo que España ha
hecho con la aprobación de esta ley
bueno y me llama la atención
especialmente el tema de las hormonas
sana porque porque No necesariamente una
persona que se quiere autopercibir
diferente quiere hacer un cambio que
tenga que pasar por la transición
hormonal No no es lo mismo una persona
transexual que una persona transgénero y
De pronto es bueno hacer esta aclaración
para nuestros televidentes claro
exactamente aquí no la queja y la
reivindicación de los colectivos era que
efectivamente te obligaban a pasar por
una serie de procesos médicos y
hormonales que no son o que no tienen
por qué ser necesarias y que no tienen
por qué ser deseados por muchas personas
que sí quieren no cambiar su sexo
registral con lo cual al final se
trataba de imponer una serie de
criterios una vez más pues externos y
patologizantes a quien quisiera
simplemente pues eso cambiar esa esa
mención registral no no sentirse no
dejar de de hay que tener un documento
de identidad con una identidad que no
era no la que acorde a sus a sus a sus
sentimientos no a identidad sentida
con lo cual Pues sí No ahora está esta
otra pionera reforma que se hace y que
beneficia a todos los cuerpos
menstruantes que nos beneficia a las
mujeres de primera mano y es esta baja
por menstruaciones dolorosas Yo quiero
preguntarle por los impactos de tomar
esta decisión porque Quienes no conocen
del tema podrían percibir que se van a
impactar por ejemplo los mercados al
hacer legal que una mujer pueda ir a
incapacitarse porque tiene una condición
de salud relacionada con su periodo
menstrual
Bueno aquí estamos expectantes por ver
bien Cómo a partir de ahora se va a
desarrollar esa Baja como las mujeres
van a poder pedir esa baja Cómo van a
reaccionar las empresas es una medida
pues pionera novedosa y hay que ver cómo
funciona
claro aquí la cosa es que en realidad
cualquier persona no si se encontraba
mal Ya podía pedir una baja médica es
decir una mujer que tuviera algún tipo
de complicación médica o que se
encontrara mal durante su menstruación
podía pedir una baja la cuestión es
primero lo hacemos o asumimos que es
algo que bueno tenemos que cargar con
ello y hay que ir a trabajar sí o sí y
segundo
están no las empresas y el sistema
entendiendo que es efectivamente puede
ser motivo de baja puede ser puede
suponer no dolor y un sufrimiento para
para las mujeres tanto no como para
cogerse una baja médica lo que hace esta
ley e incluir este concepto de baja
menstrual es tratar de cambiar eso no
tratar de fijar que sí que es un motivo
válido para asumir una baja médica que
ya lo era pero que ahora se recoge así
explícitamente y que los médicos y las
médicas del Sistema Nacional de salud
deben de conceder este tipo de bajas a
las mujeres que así lo necesiten y las
empresas tienen que asumirlo no ahora
como digo Pues habrá que ver exactamente
ya la letra pequeña no y ver y ver y ver
cómo funciona Porque efectivamente en su
momento pues hubo quejas no hubo cierto
revuelo también de las confederaciones
empresariales sobre Bueno pues hasta qué
punto y se podía asumir esto hasta qué
punto esto podía suponer una
discriminación de las mujeres creo que
en general esto se ha saltado con la
idea de que no puede ser una
discriminación no lo que no podemos
hacer es dejar de seguir invisibilizando
Cuáles son las condiciones no de de
muchas personas que menstrúan y que se
encuentra mal y que quizá no deben ir al
trabajo en esas condiciones bueno Y
además que es un reconocimiento para las
mujeres que padecen enfermedades Como
por ejemplo la endometriosis que hoy en
día están poco diagnosticada tan mal
reconocida tan mal tratada en general en
los sistemas de salud No solamente en
España sino a nivel general y pues por
otro lado también destacar que es un
cambio de simbolismo no un
reconocimiento después de que llevamos
décadas y décadas viendo por ejemplo
estos comerciales de toallas higiénicas
diciéndonos que tenemos a seguir con
nuestra vida normalmente como si no
pasara nada Y si pasa entonces
ahora esto nos plantea otros otros retos
que primero vienen para España pero que
el mundo está observando no porque estas
son medidas que podrían ser replicadas y
deberían ser replicadas en otros países
por ejemplo le preguntaba por el rechazo
de los empleadores ya cerrando porque
pues no es ningún secreto que todavía
hay gente que piensa que no es un buen
negocio contratar una mujer que se puede
embarazar que se pueden capacitar Y pues
ahora con la baja menstrual pues estas
personas se llenan de motivos para para
dar este argumento que al final es a
todas luces machista
es a todas luces machista porque claro
lo que no puede ser es que sigamos con
un sistema económico o laboral que esté
pensado y hecho a la medida de un
trabajador hombre que no tiene la regla
que no Se embaraza pero que tampoco
tienen Aparentemente no ninguna
necesidad de cuidar ni de cuidar ni de
Cuidado no porque parece que nuestro
sistema está hecho como a esa medida y
esa persona no existe No no es realista
no es un modelo realista no es un modelo
compatible con la vida real con personas
que tienen necesidades de cuidados que
tienen que ser cuidadas y que deben
también cuidar que tienen
vulnerabilidades y que son
interdependientes Yo creo que es hora de
que nuestro sistema económico y laboral
reconozca esto y se adapte a esto Porque
además la productividad la eficiencia la
calidad no están reñidas precisamente
con esto no yo creo que precisamente al
revés creo que cuando las personas son
reconocidas no en todas sus necesidades
y si
que pueden no tener una vida parte que
sus necesidades son reconocidas y
tenidas en cuenta pues probablemente
trabajen más y mejor pues ese sería el
ideal y ojalá que así sea sin embargo ya
en el cierre Ana recordar las palabras
de la ministra de la igualdad de Irene
Montero quien dijo que era muy
consciente de que el camino no terminaba
con estas reformas Y que ahora viene una
fuerte trabajo
enfrentando la resistencia que podría
darse por estas reformas y veremos Pues
cómo será el camino de la implementación
Como le decía antes está el mundo y
están las colectivas observando España
cómo le va con la aplicación de estas
reformas Y qué más puede hacer en
avances de derechos de las mujeres Le
agradezco mucho a usted por estar con
nosotros es Ana requena Aguilar
redactora en jefa y experta en género
del diario.es
venga Muchísimas gracias a vosotras y
también a nuestros televidentes Gracias
por estar con nosotros Nos vemos
Próximamente en ellas hoy y sigan en
France 24
[Música]